щоб брехня що я ще буду ці карти на та
для вираження близьких шумний вам близькі
моїх завищуємо у ю т карт йому жити викл
котович жартома агресії
адже трохи прийняти взуттєві прийняти
метафоричні асоціативні карти
психолог світлана шарапова крутого і про
ці пункти ветерану атома до свого
edjing у ви text з піци вдома сти у вас
не готовими а джек якщо поведінки з
фронту ціни готовий був і зовсім упусти
неприступне контрольоване злості
надріз шкідливих намагався домагався
колись телефон би ти посуд депутата
говори мені я не знаю ще був видалим а ви
кладете його дешевше відразу світові потрібно
зрозуміти досі труби колеса йдеш
вивестися психологічному штопору
крижаний а до пабу ванни і не повернулася
а інвалідам а максим магістратів зерг не
просто а bo3 мати більше практичних
інструментів світла шарапа минуло
уроку
почалася вона тренінгах столітті проводилася
віконцем німецького а ряду
психологи у щура хол та україни тут
що флула систем щоб ясна був і
готові ми не joan та знав і про провину
зник я за не знаю посттравматичні
стресові розлади яузу б стати лоліта
пройшла тренінги протеїн проти ти
заварюванням ст рівну закриваючись закят
шую травмами цеху соціально петр їм кота
робота з конфліктами мета проект за
дорожче рим і ряду фарин в Україні
келію німецька товари стас міжнародна
з препаратом на тренінг gough & evi
соціальний противники та волонтери з
прифронтових районі сходи України
вручають до sweet ризикових психологів та
джек держав цей проект вин потрібен для
щоб у збруї ти людей необхідними
знаннями та методами я проти ти з його
тараном і а то я противати з їхнім сім'ям
і як треба то допомогу
в сім'ї яків витрачала зло курма ельцин
avenida в сім'ї загреблі хвої його то й
як адекватно відра гуго ти в ситуації на
засоби випадки насильства в сім'ях
демобілізованих та поселенців 90 до дали
bit shy c волонтери батю своїх місцях ми
а сьогодні багато хто
люди вже переселенці бачили багата
переселенців бачіли вільну бачили всі ті
а ти там у багатого конфлікти потвори нах
прикладом у дітей синдром страху та мтс
потрібна псих логічна допомога людині
особи його агресивніші за чоловіка особливо
агресивні ветеран про те максим ільченко
за допомогою психолога за мить пастухова
на лахут це своєю жити обід колу субин
нові сторони та інтереси людині
павичі що таких консультацій пудри
буде багатий вуст їх я кевін повор
таїті звірячий від жавель солід під бате
протікання застигла захопивши those with
kevin та
було дістати не кваліфікаційних яких
сил